ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนค่ะครูเอ๋
เป็นคนเขียนใช่ไหมคะได้ค่ะได้ค่ะครูเขียน
นะคะเดี๋ยวกู a  Call แช่ screen ก่อนนะ
คะได้ค่ะผู้หญิงครูเอเขียนค่ะผู้หญิงพูด
แล้วคะผู้หญิงมองเห็นไหมคะมองไม่เห็นค่ะ
เดี๋ยวพี่เอาตัวครูให้ใหญ่ก่อนตัวเอง
เขียนได้เค้าหมดเลยนะคะถามหมดเลยมันมอง
เห็นเขียนตรงไหนก็ได้ใช่ไหมคะตรงไหนก็ได้
ค่ะคู๋โอเค
วันนี้วันอะไรคะผู้หญิงวันนี้วันอาทิตย์
ค่ะวันอาทิตย์นะคะ
วันอาทิตย์สีแดงปากกากูเอ๋เป็นอะไรมี
อวตาร Just เส้นเล็ก
วันอาทิตย์นะคะ
555 วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 15
ค่ะวันที่ 15 นะคะ
จะไปเปลี่ยนสีก่อน
วันที่ 15
ค่ะ
ใช้เมาส์ไม่ได้ไม่ขนาดนั้น
15 ราคาอ่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมค่ะเดือนพฤษภาคมใช้นิ้วเลยค่ะตอน
นี้ดีใครมั้ย
ตีขอศ.อะไรค่ะปีคศ
022 ค่ะ 2  e02  2 ปีพต
อะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะโอเคแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอน
นี้เวลา
14:00 น
55 นาที 2 โมงค่ะ
นาทีที่ใส่ค่ะหน้าโอเคเย้
ลบนะคะค่ะ
เขียนเสร็จแล้วก็ลบลบนะคะลบออกไป
ซบให้หมดดอกให้หมดผู้หญิงค่ะวันนี้ครูเอ๋
เนี่ยจะมี
คำถามครูเอ๋มากับคำถามแล้ว
พี่เอมาแล้วค่ะพี่เกดชอบมีคำถามชายขึ้น
เอ๋มีคำถามถามครูหญิงหรือถามนักเรียนคะ
ถามครูหญิงโทษขามนักเรียนด้วยนะคะ
ครูมีรูปนิดหน่อยนะผู้หญิงได้ค่ะ
ครูเอกคะอันนี้คำถามครูเอ๋ใช่ไหมคะใช่อ่ะ
โคอิเตะเอารูปให้ใหญ่ๆก็ได้ค่ะเพลงขยาย
รูปรูปขยายได้อ้ะเลื่อนได้ค่ะ
อะไรคะเนี่ยหาอ้าวผู้หญิงมีมีรูปอะไร
บ้างเนี่ยได้ครูหญิงอ่ะครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋มีรูป
มีรูปพระจันทร์
ค่ะใช้ค่ะมีรูปดาวค่ะแต่
เอ่อเอ่อรูปนี้
อะไร
ดาวตกค่ะคุย
โอเคไหมโอเคโอเคค่ะดาวตกโอเคเข้าใจเป้าใจ
ตอนนี้ดาวเวลากลางคืนคู่หญิงกลางคืน
กลางคืนก็จะเป็นสีสีสีนี่เนาะเดี๋ยวกูออก
โอ้ว
กลางคืนวุ้นนี่อ่ะกำลังคืนค่ะฟ้าสี
น้ำเงินค่ะบางทีก็เป็นสีน้ำเงินแบบนี้อ่ะ
คุยให้เป็นสีนะ
โอเค
โอเคไหมอาหารเอาเงินแล้วก็ดำๆเหมือนตีผม
ดำได้จริงๆสีน้ำเงินแต่บางทีคนไทยดูเป็น
สีดำสระอะสีคือแบบนี้เนาะแล้วตัวนั้นก็
ไม่ดำอย่างนี้เนาะใช่บางคนคิดสีดำอะสีดำ
มีไหม
ก็อะดิได้อยู่นะคะ 3 เอ๋นะเคยเห็นเป็นสี
นี้ใช่ผู้หญิงชอบสีนี้มากกว่าค่ะคือเด็ก
สีน้ำเงินนะคะเวลากลางคืนนะครับว่ามืด
ท้องฟ้าสีน้ำเงินดำๆค่ะแล้วแล้วเห็นใช่
ไหมผู้หญิงมองเห็นดาว
ตกค่ะดาวเนี่ยมีดาว 1 ดวงกำลังนั่งถ้าครู
หญิงนั่งอยู่ที่นี่พื้นคุยวัดก่อน
หากผู้หญิงนั่งตรงมิ
ผู้หญิงตัวสีเหลืองก็ได้ค่ะครูเอ๋จะได้
เห็นชัด
โอเคค่ะ
[เพลง]
เหลือเนี่ยก็
เหมือนพระจันทร์เลยนะผู้หญิงผู้หญิงนั้น
นั่งแล้วก็ดูนะคะดูดาวดูดาวดูดาวดูพระ
จันทร์น่ะค่ะชอบไหมคะชอบดูมั้ย
เอ้า
ครูเอ๋ชอบดูนะคราวเหรอคะชอบมากครูหญิงชอบ
ดูทีวีออนอุดีไม่ได้หล่ะดูโอเวอร์ผู้หญิง
ที่ไม่จริงแล้วนะดูอีก 1 ดูคอมพิวเตอร์
ค่ะวิธีกล่อง filter
คู๋ตอนเวลากูเองเด็กๆอ่ะเวลาคุยเด็กๆนี่
มีคุณพ่อ
แล้วก็แม่ค่ะพ่อเนี่ยพ่อชอบดูดาวออแล้ว
ครูเอ๋เอ๋ดูดาวกับพ่อใช่พ่อชอบให้กูเอ๋มา
มีมีเสื่อแบบอ่ะค่ะแล้วครูเอกกับพ่อก็
นั่งแล้วก็ดูดาว 2 คนครูเอ๋กรุงเทพฯไหมคะ
ไม่ใช่กรุงเทพฯค่ะพี่เอ๋ไม่ได้อยู่
กรุงเทพฯอยู่ต่างจังหวัดอ่ะจังหวัดชลบุรี
อยู่กรุงเทพตอนกลางคืนเห็นได้เขาไว้ครับ
มั้ยเห็น
เดี๋ยวเมื่อก่อนกูหญิงก็อยู่ต่างจังหวัด
ก็ไม่ดูดาวดูทีวีจริงๆคุณพ่อไม่ชวนดูดาว
หรอคะไงค่ะคุณพ่อดอกชวนดูดาวหรอคะคุณแม่
นอน
คุณคุณตาไม่ชวนดูดาวหรอค่ะคิดว่าครูหญิง
นอนแล้วคุณตาก็เลยไม่ชวน
คุณตากูหญิงคุณพ่อมีสีนะคะค่ะแต่ว่าถ้า
อะไรคะก็คุยทำไมถึงถ้าคุณหญิงดูดาวที่ผู้
a ถาม
ผู้หญิงไม่ได้ดูไม่เป็นไรดีมากครูเอ๋นะ
ชอบดูดาวค่ะคุณพ่อนะคะค่ะแล้วคุณแม่คุณ
แม่คุณแม่ดูนิดหน่อยคุณเอ๋แล้วครูเอ๋เอ๋
ดูดาวแล้วนับไหมคะหนึ่งสองสามสี่ห้านะเอก
กะนับ 1  2  3  4
ตลับหลับหน้าๆนี่ไงเทคนิคคุณพ่อให้ครูเอ๋
เอ๋หลับ
ที่นี้เนี่ยนักเรียนคะเอ่อคุณพ่อน่ะไม่
ได้ว่าอะไรกู S ดูดาวผู้เอย์ชิชี้สีสีดาว
ก็โอเคดาวชื่ออะไรแต่พี่ Order ดาวชื่อ
อะไรคุณพ่อจะบอกดาวชื่ออะไร
คุณพ่อเนี่ยรู้นิดหน่อยค่ะก็บอกรู้เหมือน
เิดิมคู่หญิงแต่คุณแม่แม่เนี่ยไม่รู้ดาว
ชื่ออะไรแม่แม่รู้นิดหน่อยข่าวว่ามี 1
ครั้งคู๋ละไปหน้าบ้านกับคุณแม่แล้วครู
เหตุครูเอกก็เห็นนะนี่ปลื้มเห็นอะไรเขา
ดาวตกค่ะเอาแล้วครูเอ๋ทำยังไงครูเห็นดาว
ตก
ครูเอกก็ชี้เลย
ตัวเองชิแม่ๆดาวตกแล้วต๋องแล้วคุณแม่บอก
ไหมดาวอะไรตกไม่ๆพ่อเเม่ตี
ทำไมคุณแม่ตีล่ะคุณแม่ตีมือคุณแม่บอกว่า
ห้ามชี้ชี้
ทำไมห้ามชี้
นี่ไงนี่คือคำถามแล้วก็คู๋ไม่ใช่โค๊กต้อง
ถามคุยหญิง
ทำไม
ทำไมคุณแม่ห้ามชี้ดาวตก
ทำไมห้ามชี้เหมือนเขาใช้ไหมคะ
A มีซอยไหมถ้ากล้วยมีสอยโอเคถ้าไม่มี
ช่วยคุยคิดได้แล้วโอเคผู้หญิงคิด
เอ้าครูหญิงคิดว่าคุณแม่ครูเอ๋บอกครูเอ๋
เอ๋ห้ามชี้ดาวตกเพราะอะไรค่ะเพราะ
ปีหน้าครูเอ๋ชี้ครูเอ๋จะไม่สบายโชคไม่ดี
มีแต่แบบไม่ดีกับครูเอ๋ออกแม่บอกห้ามชี้
ฟูผู้หญิงคิดเก่ง
ถูกไหมคะอ้าว
คุณแม่บอกว่าคุณแม่บอก
555 ไมชี่
เพราะว่าดาวเนี่ยเป็น
เทวดา
เอาอ๋ออา
เทวดาค่ะอันนี้เทวดาคุยว่าเทวดาไม่ใช่
เทวดาไทยนะค่ะทรายเทวดาไทยจะ
แฟชั่นไม่เหมือนกันนะคะแฟชั่นเยอะเลยหา
เทวดาไทยแต่ว่ายาก
คุณแม่บอกว่าอันนี้เป็นเทวดาแล้ว
อาสวะดานลงมากำลังลงมา
แล้วก็จะมีผู้หญิงน่ะผู้หญิงกำลังจะท้อง
หมอ
[เพลง]
เทวดาเนี่ยจะลงมาท้องผู้หญิง
เอาออกก็ชี้ถ้าสีไม่โอเคเหรอคะชีส
เทวดาตกใจ
แล้วเทวดาจะลงไปที่ท้องของ
ใคร
ท้องหมา
อ๋อ
ลงคิดที่
ท้องถ.ท่า kuai ชีก็เลยไม่ได้คุณแม่ก็เลย
ห้ามชีให้แม่บอกห้ามชี้ดาวตกคะดาวตกลงมา
แล้วกูอ่ะดาวตกดาวตกเทวดากำลังมามีคนรู้
น้ำตกใจลงมาผิดเลยค่ะอันนี้ไม่ดีเนาะไม่
ดีต้องมาลงท้องคนไม่ถ่ายท้องหมาอ๋ออ๋อคุณ
แม่กูเอกก็เลยห้ามชี้
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าจริงหรือไม่จริงแล้วพี่คิด
ว่าจริงค่ะค่ะ
นักเรียนไม่เป็นคิดว่าจริงหรือไม่จริง
ชี้เพราะว่าเทวดาลงมาเดี๋ยวลงผิดไม่ไปที่
คนไปที่หมาถ้าเราชีส
วิ่งคิดว่าไม่จริงพูดเอ๋
หรอเอ้าทำไมอ่ะแล้วความจริงแล้วทำไมห้าม
ชี้
ผู้หญิงคิดว่า
ชีสไม่ดีขอสีใช้นิ้วชี้มีสีขนไม่มี
คุณแม่ก็เลยหล่อก็ห้ามชี้ชายครูเอกก็จะ
ได้ไม่ชี้ไงเวลากู ah โตขึ้น
ชีไม่ดีนะคะนิ้วชี้นิ้วชี้ของได้ชิงไม่
ได้แต่ถ้าครูหญิงชี้ชี้ครูเอ๋
โทรศัพท์ครูเอ๋หนีได้หรอผู้หญิงเป็นเด็กๆ
แล้วชี้ของครูเอ๋โอเคไหมก็อันนี้เขาเป็น
อันนี้โทรศัพท์
โทรศัพท์เป็นฟรีเซนเตอร์นะ on
Music  sheet ของโอเคค่ะแต่ต้องระวังไม่
ชี้โดนคนไม่รักใช่ไหมน้องรักเนี่ย
ระพุทธรูปชี้ไม่ได้ไม่ได้พระพุทธรูปนะ
ครับอ่าทั่ว
ประเทศนักเรียนมีไหมคะดาวตกสีสีได้มั้ย
ตัวเองอยากจะรู้ประเทศนักเรียนชี้ดาวตก
ดาวตกเนี่ยเนี่ยเนาะถอยก่อนนักเรียนนอนดู
ดาวแล้วจะเห็นดาวตก
ใจที่ได้ไหม
ประเทศไทยไม่ได้นะไม่ได้
บ้านเราไม่ได้เก๋
สายๆๆแต่คนกรุงเทพไม่รู้มันทีได้แค่แต่
บ้านเราไม่ได้นะคะค่ะจริงๆพ่อโอเคแม่ไม่
ได้อ๋อ
ก็กันก็แล้วแต่คนหาว่าคุณพ่อโอเคแต่คุณ
แม่แบบ
ห้ามชี้
Oh  My  aim ดูดาวกับพ่อก็ดาวดาวดาวคุณ
พ่อฮ่าๆๆหัวเราะแบบแม่ป้าดาวแม่ไม่ได้
เฮ้ยที่
นั่งคิดดาว 1 ดวงเทวดา
1  1 ขอ
[เพลง]
ขอเพิ่มอีกไหมคะครูเอ๋เอ๋พยายามวาดรูปนะ
คะแต่ว่าไม่ทำ
เป็นเวลากลางวันนะคะเก่าไงใช่กลางคืนแล้ว
มีพระอาทิตย์ค่ะมีแม่
แล้วมีมีฝนตกค่ะอ๋อ
มีฝนตกแล้วก็มีพระอาทิตย์ก็จะเกิดอันนี้
อะไรคะคุยอิ๋งเรียกว่าอะไรรุ้งค่ะรุ้งค่ะ
รุ้ง
รุ้งหรือรุ้งกินน้ำค่ะขาย
พูดรุ้งโอเค
รุ้งกินน้ำโอเคมีกี่สีคะผู้หญิงนี่มีทั้ง
หมด 7 สีค่ะอ่ะจะเป็นสีนะคะ 7 สีสีอะไร
บ้างคะ
สีม่วง
R
สีม่วงโอเคมีมีสิ่งง่วงอ่ะเอาสีม่วงสี
อะไรคราบสีครามสีอะไรคะสีครามม่วงครามออก
ม่วงม่วงครามน้ำเงินเขียวเหลืองแสดแดงผู้
หญิงช่องแนะอ่อนส่วนคนโง่ไม่รู้โอเคเอา 7
สีแล้วค่ำห้าสีม่วงแล้วก็แบบสีน้ำเงิน
อะไรค่ะสีน้ำเงินน้ำเงิน
สีฟ้า
สีเขียวสีเขียวสี
เหลืองสีเหลือง
ค่ะสีส้ม
มีสีส้ม
แล้วก็สีแดง
สีแดง
ค่ะโอ่ยสีแดง 7 สีนะคะ 7  4
ผู้หญิงขา
มีคำถามมีคำถามค่ะ
ถามอะไรคะครูเอ๋ถามว่าเวลาที่เราเด็กๆน่ะ
เราชี้รุ้งกินน้ำได้ไหมคะไม่ได้ไม่ได้
ห้ามสีนี้ห้ามชิรุ้งกินน้ำไปคะเอ้าถ้าจะ
ครูหญิงเห็นรุ้งกินน้ำแล้วก็ชี้รุ้งกิน
น้ำนิ้ว
นิ้ว L  O  A  New  New จะหายไปใช่ไหม
เดี๋ยวจะขายใบผิงก็จะมีนิ้วโป้งนิ้วกลาง
นิ้วนางนิ้วก้อยเหลือ 4 นิ้วค่ะนิ้วชี้
เป็นยังไงคะนิ้วชี้หายไปจะเอาเล็บนิ้วกุด
หรอนิ้วกุดเธอผิดก็จะเป็นแบบนี้สวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนใช่ไหมคะมีสีนิ้ว
ผู้หญิงแล้วถ้าสมมติเรา
รุ้งกินน้ํามีความถามที่ไหนน้อสี
ไม่ได้ถ้าชี้แล้วทำยังไงเอ่อนี้จะกดนิ้ว
จะกด kuai ชี้แล้วใช่ไหมกูอ่ะเดี๋ยวถ้า
เค้าเองไม่อยากไม่อยากนิ้วกุดกูเอานิ้ว
จิ้มก๊ก
ดม
ฟิล์มอะไรนะฮะซิมก้ม
ครูเอชื่อวัดก้นหน่อยได้ไหมคะผู้หญิงกู
ไม่สามารถโตก้นได้อ่ะอ่ะ
ต้นนี่ใส่นะคะก้นก้นนะเวลาเรานะฮะพรุ่ง
นี้นะคะนักเรียนก้นอ่าอ่ะแต่
ดูเหมือนก้นมั้ยเดี๋ยวนะเดี๋ยวนะครูเอ๋
วัดใหม่วัดใหม่เออ
เอามือนิ้วดีกว่า
โอเค
[เพลง]
เหมือนกบเลยอ่ะ
อันเนี้ยส้นนักเรียนต้น
อ่ะทรายค่ะถ้า
ถ้าครูเอ๋เอานิ้วชี้รุ้งแล้วอ่ะกูเอกกลัว
นิ้วชิกุฏกูเองต้องเอานิ้วเนี่ยจิ้มก้น
ตัวเอง
ต้นใช่ไหมจิ้มก้นตัวเองนะฮะแล้วก็ดมแล้ว
จะโอเคโอเคหิวไม่คิดว่า
มาแล้วเม้นนะผู้หญิงเองครูเอกก็ต้องคิด
ที่เขาว่าครูเอ๋จะเอาเหม็นหรือว่านิ้วกุด
อ้ออ๋อโอ้โอโอเคจิ้มก่อนแล้วก็ดมอีกแล้ว
นิ้วโอเคนิ้วชี้ไหมหายไป
งั้นเนี่ยเวลาเราโดนโดนสอนว่าเฮ้ยอย่านะ
อย่าชี้รุ้งเพราะท่านเดี๋ยวนี้จะกุดถ้า
ไม่กดต้องจิ้มก้นแล้วก็ดมเราก็
ไม่ใช่อยากดมใช่มั้ยไม่สีดีกว่านะคะแล้ว
ทำไมถึงให้
ห้ามชี้จริงๆเด็กๆห้ามชี้รุ้ง
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าเหมือนห้ามชี้ดาวตกไหมคะก็
คือชี้ไม่ดี
เหมือนกันค่ะมี
เธอเก่งมากมีเวลาไม่ใช่วิ่งไม่ใช่คน
กรุงเทพฯก็เลยรู้มีเวลาค่ะครูเอ๋
[เพลง]
กูเองไม่เล่น
มีอีกประมาณเกือบ 10 นาทีได้ค่ะโอเคต่อไป
พูดเอ๋มีอันนี้นะคะมี
อะไรคะอาจารย์ช่องทางกูเอสวยจัง
ลาน
เปลี่ยนกินข้าวหรอคะ
ยังไม่กินข้าวแต่ให้รู้จักก่อนจานอ๋อ
มีก็มีส้อมค่ะ
มี
ช้อน
มีอะไรคะมีมีดค่ะ
แล้วก็มีตะเกียบค่ะแล้วแต่ใช้อะไรคู่เอก
จะใช้ช้อนแล้วก็ซ่อมเหมาะสำหรับกินข้าว
ค่ะแต่ถ้านั่งแล้วรอคุณแม่ทำอาหารและ
คูเวต
ๆ
โอเคมั๊ยคะวิเคราะห์จานหรอใช่ขอโทษนะครับ
ขอโทษก่อนครับหิวข้าว
เพราะจานจะให้เธอไม่ได้
ทำไมอ่ะโอเคสต๊อกสกรีน
ทำไมกูเอะอะเพราะจ๋าจ้าครูเอ๋ Action ขอ
โทษนะคะขอโทษนะคะคุณรู้แล้ว
สารสินก็ไม่รู้หรอก
กูเอ้ยกินข้าวคนไทยข้ามขอบจานใช่ไหมคะใช่
ค่ะคนไทยเนี่ย
เสียงดังไม่ได้ไม่ได้และห้ามเคาะจานทำไม
ข้อจานไม่ได้
ผู้หญิงคิดว่า
คิว
นี้มา
ใช่ไหมผีเหยื่อ
ท้ายถ้าครูเอกเคาะนะเนี่ยทีก็กี้กำลังทำ
อะไรอยู่ครูเอกข้อที่เกาะ
ผีมาใช่ไหมเขาบอกว่าถ้าเราจะกินข้าวแต่
เรารอคุณแม่เอาอาหารมาแล้วเราเคาะเคาะๆ
จาน
เป็นเรียบผีผีผีมากินข้าวคง
โอเคเนาะมีเพื่อนเอารู้
กลัวชอบทีม
คอร์ปๆๆๆผีจะมามาไม่ใช่ผีที่เราโอ้
โหไม่ใช่ผีคุณไม่ใช่ผีที่บ้านไม่ใช่ผี
ครอบครัวเราเหนที่อื่นจะไม่ใช่มั้ยไม่เอา
ไม่เอากลัวบางทีผีบ้าบ่ๆ
แล้วจะเขกไม่ได้กินข้าวหายเพราะจานนะคะ
เอาจานช้อนช้อนส้อมเคาะไม่ได้เอ้าครูเอ๋
แล้วถ้าเอาช้อนเอาส้อมเคาะเคาะกันเองไป
ได้ไหมมีได้เหมือนกันไหมอย่างนี้มาจะมา
กินข้าว
อันนี้อันนี้คนไทยนะคะคนไทยและ a นะจริง
ไหม
จริงมาให้เรียนลองดู
นักเรียนลองดูนะคะผีมาไหมไม่ได้ข้าวให้
นักเรียนกลัวเอาไม่เอาไม่เอาแล้วเนี่ยเขา
สอนให้เราน่ะกินข้าวเบาเบาๆ
เป็นเราผู้หญิงใช่ไหมคะไม่มีเสียง
ไอเป็นผู้หญิงกินเผ่าเบา
r&d มาก
ทรายเบาเบาๆเสียงดังไม่ดีนะคะให้เรียบ
ร้อยและเด็กๆไม่ฟังค่ะชายคุณแม่บอกว่ากิน
เบาๆ
เด็กๆก็เลยต้องบอกผีมา
เอาบังอ่ะถ้าคนใช้ตะเกียบไม่ดังใช่ไหมแต่
ว่าท่านที่มีชามข้าวแล้วก็เกือบตั้งตรงๆ
ขอได้ไหมคะผู้หญิงไม่ได้
ทำไมคะอันนี้คนตายมากก็เป็นข้าวสำหรับคน
ตายเอ้อผีไปได้ไม่ได้นะคะไม่ได้ครูเอ๋
แล้วถ้า
ถ้าไม่ใช่ข้าวอ่ะคะครูหญิงเนี่ยกิน
ก๋วยเตี๋ยว
อันนี้เป็นเท่าถ้วยมีน้ำซุปแล้วก็มี
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวมีลูกชิ้น
แล้วผู้หญิงเอาตะเกียบลงแบบนี้ได้ไหมคะ R
ถ้าวางแบบนี้ยังๆได้ตรงไม่ได้ก็โอเคถ้า
ตรงตรงไม่ได้ตรงอันนี้ไม่ดีจริงๆไม่เป็น
ไรค่ะอ๋อ
มีอะไรอีกอ่ะมีอีกแปลง
อันนี้อันนี้ไม่เอ้ยคนไทย
คนไทยโอเคกับคนต่างชาติคิดไม่เหมือนกัน
นิดนึงยางอันนี้ไม่ใช่คนไทยนะคะนักเรียน
ทำอะไรอ่ะใช่คนไทยของน้ำอ่า
โอเคของน้ำห้องน้ำ
ห้องน้ำเนี่ย
ห้องน้ำอันนี้เป็นห้องส้วมใช่ไหมคะ
โถส้วม
แล้วตรงนี้เป็นฝาค่ะอันนี้เป็นถังน้ำ
ถังน้ำของส้วมที่ที่
บ้านครูหญิงอ่ะผู้หญิงปิดฝาไหมคะหน้าๆค่ะ
ผู้หญิงไม่ปิดดอกไม้ใช่ไหมคะไม่ปิดฝาที่
บ้านครูเอ๋ปิดฝาไหมคะ
มะคุ่คนเดียวไม่ปิดไฟอ้าวแวะสามีคู๋หน้า
แต่งงานนะคะแต่งงานมิสเตอร์ Japan
สามีเป็นคนญี่ปุ่นสามีเบาะปิดฝาคู๋บอก
เปิดฝาปิดฝาเปิดฝา OO ทะเลาะกัน
กูเองให้คำถามคนญี่ปุ่นคนญี่ปุ่นอันนี้
ไม่ใช่คนไทยละคนญี่ปุ่นน่ะบอกว่าห้องน้ำ
ต้องปิดฝาอา
ทำไมต้องปิดฝา
ไม่เหม็น
เขาว่า and
ถ้าเปิดโชว์
ดีไม่ดีหรอคะ
ทำไมอ่ะไม่เข้าใจถ้าถ้าปิดฝาเนี่ยโชคดี
ถ้าเปิดฝาเนี่ยเงินบ๊ายบาย
เค้าก็โชคไม่ดีอ่ะอ๋อเหมือนเงินที่นี่ถ้า
เปิดเงินหมดช้อปปิ้งซื้อของไม่มีงานไม่มี
ออฟฟิศไวเงินอยู่ในส้วมเอ้าเวลาครูเอนอน
ฝันเห็นมันคือเงินนะ
บอกว่าชอบปิดฝาเนี่ยอออเงินจะอยู่ที่นี่
งานจะมามามามาให้ปิดฝานะคะ
เงินไม่มา
แต่ครูเอ๋ไม่ชอบเลยบ่เปิดจะได้ดูสะอาดไม่
สะอาด
คนภัยไม่มีว่าเมื่อก่อนห้องน้ำคนไทยไม่
ใช่แบบนี้นะว่าคนไทยไม่ปิดราคาคนไทยไปปิด
ค่ะแต่อะไรก็คือปิดก็ดีค่ะเพราะว่าถ้า
เปิดน่ะอย่างผู้หญิงบอกอ่ะมีแค่มีไวรัสมี
แบคทีเรียมันออกส่วนมิกซ์รินมีอะไรเราไม่
สบาย
ไม่สบายก็ต้องจ่ายเงิน
ชายค่ะไม่สบายก็ต้องเงินนเงินหมดงั้นปิด
ฝาดีกว่าแต่ตอนนี้ตัวเองต้องปิดฝาเราก็จะ
เข้าห้องน้ำก็เปิดฟ้าใช้เสร็จก็ปิดเปิด
ปิดเปิด
เปิดเงินก็ออกมั้ยฮะ
แต่ไม่รู้ประเทศนักเรียนมีไหมนะเหมือนคน
ญี่ปุ่นมั้ยใช่ไหมกูเอ๋แต่คนไทยมายนะคะ
แต่คนไทยบอกว่าต้องทำสะอาดสะอาด
อยู่ในห้างไม่ต้องปิดไม่ต้องปิดแต่ห้อง
น้ำต้องสะอาด
หอมผ้าสะอาดแล้วแข็งแรงโชคดีต่อมีเงิน
ต่ายค่ะอันนี้นิดบ้านครูเอ๋นะคะคุณค่าบอก
ห้องน้ำสะอาดจะแข็งแรงต้องถูกเหมือนนึกๆ
คุณป้าให้ครูเอ๋ทำความสะอาดห้องน้ำโถๆให้
อ้อมดาวสะอาดสิ่งห้องน้ำสะอาดก็ดีนะแข็ง
แรงไม่มีไวรัสไม่มีแบคทีเรียๆก็ต้องอาบ
น้ำแล้วก็ถูกห้องน้ำ 1 ชั่วโมงค่ะ
แข็งแรงเลยนะ
ใส่ค่ะวันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้นะคะคนไทยสอน
เด็กๆนะคะ 5 ขอคำชี้ดาวตกราคา
ห้ามสีอะไรอีกครั้งห้าม Shake รุ้งค่ะ
อา
อันนี้คนญี่ปุ่นฮะแล้วก็ห้ามเคราะห์จารย์
เวลากินข้าว
จานน่ะไม่ได้นะคะห้ามจริงๆกินข้าวนี่นี่
ห้ามอีกนะห้ามพูดห้ามๆปากเวลามีข้าวแล้ว
ไม่ได้ไม่ได้นี่นักเรียนน่าจะเหมือนเรา
เนาะได้ครับก็ที่บ้านครูเอ๋พิเศษอ่ะห้าม
เปิดฉันไม่ได้นะเดี๋ยวแบบนี้เปิดอยู่
เนี่ยห้ามนะคะบ้านครูเอ๋ไม่ได้ติดล่ะคะ
ปิด
ตายค่ะนอนแต่ว่าวันนี้หมดเวลาออกมาแล้ว
ค่ะครูเอ๋หมดเวลาแล้วผู้หญิงกับครูเอกก็
ต้องลาได้แรงใช่ค่ะแล้วเดี๋ยวเจอกันใหม่
วิดีโอหน้าถ้าป่าสวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบายค่ะ